The
next excerpt is taken from original take W. seventy four.
This
is Mrs Franklin D. Roosevelt regular Sunday evening broadcast sponsored by the Pan
American coffee bureau representing seven good neighbor coffee growing
nations on this the Sunday of Christmas week and the third Sunday of armed conflict.
Mrs Roosevelt has a message so important we shall take time to say only these few words from
our
sponsors they are words quoted from a recent maybe the private memorandum and they read as
follows It is a known fact that coffee plays an important part in the morale among
the personnel of the
Navy in total war high morale is needed not only by our armed
forces but by every civilian as well coffee gives the extra energy.
The study your nerves which are so much a part of the kind of morality. We all must
have coffee more than ever before is the America's necessary
drink and now we present Mrs Franklin D. Roosevelt.
Good evening ladies and gentlemen. There is one thing about the American people
when any in the agency arises. It seems to spend them on to
greater activity and the more difficult the task may be the more ready they are
to meet the situation.
I imagine that is a trait common to all their old people I
have noted many times that there are people who lose interest in anything
the minute it becomes easy to accomplish but who were willing tiring day
as long as the problem befall them is
challenging facts. This is a trait. Does the American people as a whole.
In any case the realisation that we are actually at war and that we have
a tremendous problem to solve because we are completely making over
the trend of
thought which the majority of our people has built up for the past twenty
years. Does not seem to phase us in any way. Instead of
the cast down. We seem to feel that this is a challenge to our ability
to adapt ourselves and still not give up the main object.
Dave's soul which we've been looking through the past twenty is.
A short time ago. I'm sure the vast majority of the people in
this country hoped that we would not get into the world
or if we faced the disagreeable fact that we
probably would have to come in at some point.
We did not think of it in concrete terms. Neither was world with
Japan nor as war with Germany and Italy.
If anyone said we might go to war with Japan the attitude was always
that we would be so superior to the Japanese that poor
little Japan would be right to all the
math. We were a very cocky or perhaps we would
just ignorant. In any case it had the same effect because it
lulled us into a state of mental and spiritual unpreparedness.
The moment that it all seems that we never face. What a victory for
the Axis powers might mean even if it was only a victory in
Europe with York dominated by the Axis powers and their
ideas. What would it mean to us to
have just across the Atlantic.
Our own continent of people who did not believe in private
industry who did not believe in trade union. Who did
not believe in the rights of the individual to life liberty and the pursuit
of
happiness. At least they would not be allowed to express their beliefs. If
they retained them there would be a whole continent of people subset of
the into the ideas that the state is paramount and that their thorough
web I.E. maybe is now. X. to God in fact.
Practically it takes its place and that by right of this that
ancestry their race should rule the world.
Ideas spread. And it will not take very long for these ideas to cross the ocean.
We know how easily a small groups of fascism Nazis and Communists in
this country have influenced the thinking of some of our
citizens and yet we lulled ourselves to sleep with the
idea that a horrible continent could be
bent on making these series succeed. And
we would be left to pursue our interests and develop our
friendships with our neighbors on this side of the
ocean untouched and an influence. We look
back now when this frame of mind seems incredible.
Suddenly as the Japanese planes flew over a wry and our
other island possession. And it gave to the American people and in
town a new realization of what the widow than the
future dominated by access methods and ideas would rarely be alive.
And over night we were a people welded together. No longer.
Divided run great united people for the period of
the
struggle. Nothing exemplifies this more clearly than the industrial
labor conference which met this past week and which was addressed to the president as
its opening session. He said to these
gentleman that he had asked them to come together to help when the wall
as they were as important in this effort as the men in military
uniform the president further said that two moderators would preside over the
group run from the executive and run from the legislative branch of the
government and that he hoped they would achieve a complete agreement and above all speed.
He wanted as much speed in turning out materials and the defense industries
as he expected from the armed forces of the nation.
Fortunately for us.
We are geographically very well located
our territory is so great that it is hard to concentrate on aerial attacks in the
way which has been done in England on such cities as London
Plymouth Manchester or Glasgow Scotland.
Production has got to rise in this country to tremendous heights.
Because we have the ability to produce and greatest speed than any other nation
in the
wounded. President told to management as well as to the with
because an effort will of course be made by the animate to take us again on a way
as to raid some city where there is a big defense industry.
And when these attempts are made they will have to our objectives run to slow
up industry and to to break civilian morale.
Being ride left scattered over great stretches of territory is an advantage to us.
It also has disadvantages however because of the fact that it would be easy to
spot us today and to attempt to attack vulnerable points using the
same methods which they've used so well in the past.
People rarely worry about what is happening to them as long as they are not directly hit.
But they were immediately about what may be happening to their families. Therefore it will
be part of the pack takes of the attacker to rest because many Wickers homes
as possible.
There are only a comparatively few people in management their homes
are not easy to find but there are a great many a
workers and because they live close together the production can be great
to slow down if the workers leave their machines to find out what has happened to their families.
It does not mean that we can expect the impossible of people given an attack.
Cannot expect that if word comes that certain parts of the city had
damaged the people whose families live there will remain it will not go to their rescue.
We can do a world that is humanly possible however to keep ourselves on the
alert and prepare for this type of
attack. Our people can know what to do when air raid warning
sound if they leave the house where they have little protection they can find new places of
protection nearby which are somewhat more substantial.
My friend Lady reading writes that night after night she had slept under I had a dining room
table and I gather that if you are weary enough that accustoms enough to air raids.
You can even sleep through the noise and confusion of a
blitz President went on any speech to point out that
this means a complete self discipline and putting aside of
this no interest.
Every one of us is going to have he said of this known mouth. Young
Captain Kelly who don't visit plane onto a Japanese battleship had nowhere does
to sacrifice his life in that way it was his own personal
mess and that is how in one way or another all about us are going to
meet situations in our with God in our lives.
Labor and many labor and management what off for a quick agreement to
speed up production.
They were told plain lay that the war is serious that we've not won it yet that
civilization is at stake for the rest of the welder's well as for us and that we have a
responsibility to maintain and increase our capacity as the arsenal
of the civilized with.
That same obligation rests on every government with God on
every individual carrying on his own job day by day he must make
it a better job so that the community in which he lives will be
strengthened by.
It read. Son every housewife of the country to run our home a little
better and to meet her difficulty is with ingenuity.
We are a very fortunate nation even at war because of far as we now
see we will have no shortage of food or of clothes to be sure we may not
have the variety we've had and I should not be surprised to see great
standardisation go into effect on many
things but we will have the wherewithal to keep
ourselves worming winter. Unlike the German people who have been
asked to sacrifice a long worm clothes for all
the army. We will have shelter. We will have all the real essential of
living many people in other parts of the world will go without these essential so I
have them rapidly in drastic take a tailored as individuals we will
hope to remember the Chinese proverb which the president quoted to the gentleman
in industry and labor. Neuroma drew a flood and I
will again ing with me.
Not just Wednesday afternoon when I face the students of many South and
Central American countries and a few European countries. I
was strangely moved that the thought of what these young people are
facing at this Christmas
season and as we approach this Christmas time in a with a rack
with walls. I'd like to remind you again to make your donation to the American Red
Cross this great organization is making a drive for fifty million
dollars to carry on the tasks which they know the next year must
brain their job will not be easy to do your
part to make by making a substantial
contribution making it does your Christmas gift. To a suffering and bewildered
word for I think that you will agree with me the Red Cross more than any
other group lives than with expire the simple words. That have come down from
the first Christmas your a to God in the highest stand on a piece
of good will toward men.
Somehow it's difficult to think got to really have much Christmas spirit this year
and yet in the deepest sense we should all of us try to emphasize the spiritual
values which have made this celebration lived through the dark
ages in a way where love thy neighbor seems to have lost its real
meaning and where consideration for little children is as academic as learning a dead language.
We must still remember that everything we fight for today is typified in the
Christmas story and that then we may not have a mayday Christmas.
We must still have a hope for one. And Sunday this present orgy of
hate and wall will come to an end. Then there must be somewhere in the with the flame
of
love then ing brightly enough to give the people of the room the confidence to
fight for a new world order in which peace and goodwill will
depend Mrs Roosevelt the Pan American coffee bureau is proud to bring
such a message to the hearts of this nation on this Christmas Sunday and we would like to
join with you in wishing everyone to use your word
a hopeful Christmas to all the families who are lucky enough to have sons back on
furlough from the services for Christmas and drop those drop for the folks or inviting
boys from neighboring post for Christmas dinner we have one suggestion to make be
sure you serve. Plenty of
coffee for the average boy in the Army and the Navy drinks just about four cups a
day they know coffee gives them the extra energy and the study nerves
their military work
demands it can do the same for you it will do the same for
you next week Mrs Roosevelt will be with us again at the same time
until then this is Dan Seymour saying good evening for the Pan American coffee bureau and don't
forget that good night cup of coffee.
If you are worried about last minute Christmas gifts. Has the answer defense bonds
and stamps will make perfect presents for anyone on your list get them tomorrow.
Do your part in this great fight for freedom.
This is the National Broadcasting
Company.